so as we get into age of Ultron issue
number six we're going to be seeing this
really really cool story playing out
because what's going to happen is we're
going to transition between the future
and the past but what we're going to
learn are a couple things the first is
we're going to learn exactly how bleak
the future is but what we're also going
to learn is what happens when you go
into the past and you make changes that
just because one action takes place
doesn't necessarily mean that there are
not going to be massive ramifications
and in fact we're actually going to
learn that the actions of Wolverine here
are going to stretch far beyond the age
of Ultron story and is actually going to
be used by Marvel to introduce
characters later on down the line
there's going to be used to introduce
characters from other alternate
realities into the Marvel Universe
although of course that will take place
beyond the scope of the age of Ultron
event but what we see as we start this
story is of course that Wolverine has
used dr. Doom's time platform and is
emerging from where the bunker would
have been in its geographical location
but of course he's in the past here and
what he does is for the most part just
explore the immediate area of the Savage
Land the immediate area of the cave to
ensure that everything's okay to make
sure that there's no trap going on here
that the Ultron robots aren't present
that there's no I guess excavation or
investigation or the presence of anyone
that isn't supposed to know that he's
there but as he's moving around he
realizes that he's not alone and so what
he tells this person is to show
themselves and what we learn is that the
person that followed him is Susan storm
now initially Susan storm was supposed
to join nick fury's team in the future
as they attempted to enter the base of
ultron and to defeat Ultron but she had
stayed behind and when Wolverine asked
her about this she says that she had a
change of heart when she saw that
Wolverine wanted to kill Hank Pym and
that the look that he had in his eye was
a look to indicate that he would not be
a swage that he would not be moved from
this mindset and so as soon as Captain
America who had told him not to go into
the past had left with Nick Fury to go
into the future she knew that Wolverine
was going to try to use the the platform
to travel into the past and try to kill
Hank Pym and so what she does and what
her and Wolverine get involved with is
this really cool debate this really cool
discussion that is logic versus morality
then this is one of the best parts of
the age of Ultron event because what
she's saying here is that this is a
moral problem that Wolverine is
encompassing that Wolverine is
representing here Wolverine is taking
the stance that in order to more or less
save lives that a person has to die and
she initially again says that she knows
this is wrong that in her heart of
hearts she can't say that this is
something okay to do but then Wolverine
replies by saying that if somebody put a
gun to one of her children's head would
she kill them would she do whatever she
needed to do to save their lives
and initially she's a little hesitant to
answer but Wolverine says that of course
she would but of course she would kill
whoever it was that was trying to harm
her children Wolverine says that this is
more or less the same thing but that it
involves countless people and so for
Wolverine this is a logical stance this
is more or less this utilitarian stance
that in order to satisfy the needs of
the many that the few are going to have
to die and so for Wolverine again this
is very simple one man Hank Pym created
Ultron and because he created Ultron the
future has turned out the way that it
has and so he rationalizes that if he
goes back and kills one man he can save
billions of people and so initially
again Susan storm hasn't necessarily
sided with this but she is somewhat
understanding of his opinion somewhat
understanding of his stance even if only
insofar that she recognizes she would
still have her children and her family
if Hank Pym wasn't alive but before
either of them can debate any further
there seems to be some kind of
disturbance coming closer towards
whither located at and what we see is
that a very young version of Nick Fury
has arrived here in its hover car and of
course this seems to be around the time
that Nick Fury has discovered this
bunker or discovered this location which
may be an optimal place for him to build
a bunker we don't really know why he's
here yet this is simply just a chance
for Marvel to introduce a way for them
to gain some sort of transportation to
the city which of course is what they do
when they steal the vehicle of Nick Fury
when Nick Fury comes out of course he
finds his vehicle gone and Wolverine and
Susan storm make their way back to to
New York City now at this point we
transition to the future and what we see
is that Quicksilver along with
the other forces of Nick Fury have
arrived at wherever this place happens
to be which is revealed to us to be the
Savage Land but rather than finding a
place that is devoid of any and all kind
of life a place that has been absolutely
ravaged like what we had seen before
they had travelled into the future we
instead see a Savage Land that is much
better off a Savage Land that appears to
be pristine in its nature then of course
you have a various I guess dinosaurs
flying around you have a very clean and
a very beautiful sort of environment and
they find this a little strange here
they didn't expect this they expected
that everything was going to be totally
trashed and everything was going to be
totally destroyed and so we see that as
they're trying to figure things out that
Captain America realizes somebody is
gone and of course Nick Fury realizes
this as well and Iron Man comments and
says that that Susan storm was supposed
to be with them Nick Fury at this point
gets very angry and the reason why is
because Susan storm was supposed to be
their stealth component she was supposed
to be the person to sneak in but again
Ironman comments and says it really
wouldn't have done any good to have had
Susan storm here and the reason why is
because while she can be invisible that
Ultron most likely has some kind of
thermal imaging program set up and so
the cameras would have immediately
detected her body heat they wouldn't
have been able to say would have been
able to see her and so it really
wouldn't have made any sense to have her
around but again Nick Fury says that
this is supposed to be a black-bag
mission this is supposed to be a black
ops mission and that people just simply
can't go rogue and so what he tells
Quicksilver is to scout the area to
travel to New York City and to try to
find whatever he can to inform them what
it is it's taking place we also see him
calling on storm to give them some mode
of transportation and to have earthquake
make sure that there's nothing that
would attack them in the immediate
vicinity of course using her powers to
create earthquakes to shell off any kind
of foe that would attempt to attack them
we also see him calling on Red Hulk on
Thunderbolt Ross and telling him that
he's going to be the backup for
earthquake so that if there are some
measure of forces that are beginning to
overwhelm her that he can jump in and he
can attempt to overthrow those forces as
well at this point we transitioned back
to Susan storm and Wolverine of course
again there
the past in the 1960s I would go as far
as to say and what they were doing here
is again investigating the area but for
Susan storm this is very weird for her
of course Wolverine comments and says
that he thought the Fantastic Four had
time traveled on multiple occasions the
Susan storm says that's the case but
that she's never time traveled back into
her own past and presumably landed on
her own front door this is something
that she's not used to and so what we
see is that as soon as they land that
Wolverine has picked up the scent of a
hanky hem and the two of them begin to
track this scent back to its origin at
this point we realized that hank pam is
experimenting on dragon man and again
dragon man is a character that had been
created or introduced in Marvel Comics
as kind of what you saw back in that
period of time where you saw these sort
of hokey or somewhat interesting kind of
villains as opposed to villains that
were more down-to-earth that were more
basic inhuman in nature and what he's
doing is more or less just analyzing
dragon man he's really just looking at
what it is is taking place here
performing various experiments trying to
understand the technology that went into
creating him but as he's trying to
figure this out will reign arise and
Wolverine says that Hank ham is the
reason for the end of the future he's
the reason why everything has gone south
and of course Hank Pym is a little
overwhelmed here Hank Pym doesn't
realize what's going on he doesn't know
what's taking place and he asked
Wolverine who he is
Wolverine introduces himself by saying
that he's the ghost of Christmas future
that he's the one that's going to
correct the mistakes that Hank Pym had
made but that he knows that Hank Pam
even if he's told don't create Ultron is
going to create Ultron anyway not
necessarily because he wasn't told to
but because he's curious to see what
would happen if he did and so Wolverine
rationalizes that there is no way out of
this situation for Hank Pym there's no
way for Hank Pym to survive this and so
he's decided that he is going to be the
one that's going to kill Hank Pym from
this one we travel back to the future
and what we see is Nick Fury Nick Fury's
forces arrive is that the entire eastern
seaboard has been converted into some
form of machinery that everything that
the entire area is for the most part
devoid of life now we don't know if the
entire planet is devoid of any kind of
human life or if the entire planet it
houses some measure of
in life although they may be hiding out
in various locations but what Tony Stark
comments here is that despite the fact
that this is a very bleak outlook
despite the fact that this is a very
dark future with regards to humanity and
the fact that all humanity may very well
have been eradicated by Ultron that the
entire landscape here the entire I guess
machined a series of machine structures
here is something he finds to be very
beautiful but almost immediately after
the superheroes arrive here the invading
forces of Ultron begin to I guess we can
to attack them and of course earthquake
uses her powers to manipulate
earthquakes to stave off a vast portion
of these of these BOTS and of course Red
Hulk himself is able to assist her as
well but then we see that in the
background more forces or arriving and
this is what happens with the
superheroes Nick Fury's team as well
rain had told us had no real chance here
that Ultron knew they were coming and
that Ultron would have prepared defenses
but even then the superheroes admit they
weren't really prepared for this kind of
a situation they didn't believe that
they would end up in a scenario whereby
there was no human life whatsoever and
that the entire planet may most likely
have been inhabited by the forces of
Ultron and so for the most part the
Ultron robots again continued their
overwhelming barrage on the superheroes
and from this point we transition back
to the past
and we see that Wolverine is attacking
Hank Pym he's attempting to kill Hank
Pym but as he's trying to kill him he's
explaining things to him he's talking to
him he tells Hank Pym that of course he
knows that he did good in the world that
he did some great things but in this
instance the one act of creating Ultron
outweighs any great thing he did because
creating Ultron led to such a bleak
future it led to such a terrible
situation but as he's preparing to deal
the killing blow to a Hank Pym Susan
storm arrives and Susan storm says that
they can't do this that they can't kill
Hank Pym that killing Hank Pym could
very well have consequences that none of
them are prepared for from this point we
switch back to the future again and we
see that all these superheroes on Nick
Fury's team are being completely
overwhelmed by Ultron's forces we of
course see that storm is killed we see
that various superheroes are doing the
best they can but in the
and there's really nothing they can do
due to the sheer number of Ultron robots
we also transition back to Susan storm
and Wolverine and Wolverine rationalizes
that again that Hank Pan by virtue of
his actions killed everybody and so
again Susan storm says that there has to
be some kind of a line here there has to
be some road that they don't cross
somewhere where they say that there's a
difference between them and those that
would go to the extremes to achieve
their own goals from here we transition
back to the future again and this is
what we see we see this bouncing back
and forth between the past and the
future and we see that Wolverine as he's
trying to kill Hank Pym as he's making
his argument to kill Hank Pym that we're
seeing various superheroes dying for
example Captain America is had his head
blown off Nick Fury of course is being
overwhelmed and again Wolverine is
saying that everything that's turned out
the way that it has has done so because
of the actions of Hank Pym and this is
when Susan storm begins to acquiesce she
begins to give in and she realizes that
so many people that billions of people
are dead because of what Hank Pym had
done that billions of people are dead
because of what it is that he had
thought up and so while Hank Pym is
initially surprised to see that Susan
storm is giving in that eventually he's
killed by Wolverine with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and I will catch you guys in the
next video peace